there was a really interesting email
that the house committee acted here and
I mean I just pulling up this image
because this is just an amazing
redaction uh that many journalists were
trying to get for a long time the house
committee was able to get it you know
the unredacted version says folks the
call with Jeremy Farrar welcome Trust
redacted
happy to chat with any of you about this
best regards Tony that's what we got out
of that the the unredacted material is
actually fairly interesting I'm going to
zoom in here
um he's talking about these discussion
these early discussions that he had with
Anderson and the team and
um that they had the suspicion that uh
they're you know it had been
manipulation which was heightened by the
fact that scientists in Wuhan University
are known to have been working on gain a
function experiments to determine
molecular mechanisms associated with bat
viruses adapting to human infection and
the outbreak originated in Wuhan so
right there beginning of the pandemic is
fauci laying out that he knew about the
gain of function experiments in Wuhan he
knew this was a possibility he also knew
about these studies that had occurred
there you mentioned Ralph Barrick
earlier this is one of the famous
studies which is a collaboration between
uh she who was the head of the Wuhan
Institute of virology and Ralph Barrick
a major researcher at UNC I believe and
in this study they
created a chimeric virus from about
coronavirus in a mouse adapted sarskov
backbone so they created exactly the
kind of like prototype you would expect
in this this kind of research and here's
the kicker the acknowledgments research
was supported by grants from the
National Institute of allergy and
infectious disease and National
Institute of aging and the U.S National
Institutes of Health so Collins and
fauci's agencies this is a January 27th
email where
um fauci's being alerted for the first
time that his agency sent money to
Eco Health which is the group that was
you know collaborating with the Wuhan
Institute of virology on This research
so very early on
he was aware that these were issues that
were were in the air and so in light of
all that
I want to play kind of the the famous
back and forth clip between uh Anthony
fauci and Rand Paul where he puts this
question directly to him and you know it
it got a certain reaction at the time uh
but now that we know more uh I just like
people to to see it again maybe in a new
light so let's uh let's pull up that
clip
or
This research matches these are Dr
ebright's words this research matches
indeed epitomizes the definition of gain
of function research done entirely in
Wuhan
for which there was supposed to be a
federal pause
Dr fauci knowing that it is a crime to
lie to Congress do you wish to retract
your statement of May 11th where you
claimed that the NIH never funded gain
of function research in wu-on
senator Paul I have never lied before
the Congress and I do not retract that
statement this paper that you are
referring to was judged by qualified
staff up and down the chain as not being
gain of function
let me finish Shake an animal virus and
you increase his responsibility to
humans right you're saying that's not
gain a function yeah that is correct and
and senator Paul you do not know what
you are talking about quite frankly and
I want to say that officially you do not
know what you are talking about okay you
all right it's official he does not know
what he's talking about what's your
reaction to that uh Matt Ridley
well
um uh
if you go back to that exchange
there is a sort of justification for
what Tony fauci is saying it's not a
very good one but it's it's one that he
was clinging to which is that there are
various definitions of gain of function
and the specific definition in the U.S
funding issue is that you improve a
human virus not an animal virus to make
it more infectious to humans right that
was that's the the angel on the head of
the pin that he's that he's dancing on
but
um as you say then why was he using the
phrase gain of function to describe this
work months earlier uh in that email and
if you can just pull up that
um uh hugely redacted email again yeah
it's pretty clear to me because that
email doesn't say anything terribly
interesting apart from that it's pretty
clear to me that the reason for
redacting that email under the Freedom
of Information Act
um uh the reason for adapting the whole
email
was to save Anthony fauci's vase after
that exchange with Rand Paul it's hard
to believe that there was any other
reason for doing that yeah it's
certainly not to protect sources or to
um uh not invade the privacy of someone
else or you know that kind of thing the
the the the the legitimate excuses for
redaction are not there this was a
political redaction of an email
in view of that exchange that had
already happened
could I bring up uh someone whose name
you mentioned earlier in passing Ralph
Barrick you mentioned he's a very
important and in uh you know
accomplished researcher who seems to be
you know on the periphery here what can
you tell us about the person of Ralph
Barrick and his importance to this
conversation
well Ralph Barrick is probably the
premier coronavirus researcher in terms
of his ability to to manipulate these
viruses he developed several techniques
including this reverse genetics
technique which is essentially a way of
as it were going from a sequence that
you want to a live virus
he developed the so-called noseeum
technique which is named after a biting
Midge that you don't see because it's so
small which is effectively a way of
altering the genes of coronaviruses in
such a way that you don't leave any
scars any joins
um uh he was really the the person who
was doing spectacular new work on
coronaviruses he had an idea about how
to develop vaccines in this area Etc
but he's working mainly on a this is
these obscure coronaviruses that
nobody's terribly interested in and the
long comes SARS won in 2003 and suddenly
it's a much bigger deal and then MERS
and uh suddenly coronaviruses are of
great interest to the world uh so when
the XI Zhang Li lab gets involved in
coronavirus research because they
basically are hunting down the origin of
SARS one is where how they start
um and then they want to get into much
more molecular work
they want to learn from Ralph Barrick
but he doesn't have access to SARS like
coronaviruses because there are no uh
horseshoe bats in North America and All
Stars like coronaviruses live in
horseshoe bats
so they come to an arrangement that XI
Jung Li will supply some of the
viruses that he needs to work on if he's
going to work on SARS like coronaviruses
in exchange for her learning some of the
techniques of reverse genetics and
genetic manipulation from him so
although both their names are on that
paper that
menageries paper
um uh very very important and
significant sort of groundbreaking paper
in 2015 none of that worked on that
paper was done in in Wuhan it was done
in North Carolina but
following that paper the XI jong-li lab
led by Ben who and Peng Zhou is rapidly
trying to catch up with
um Ralph Barrick by
emulating his techniques and one of the
most important documents that we haven't
talked about yet
which is the one that really persuaded
my co-author Alina Chan and myself to
come off the fence the so-called diffuse
proposal was a request to DARPA in the
Pentagon for money to do work on SARS
like coronaviruses that would include
inserting Fury and cleavage sites into
them for the first time and that work
was to be done in North Carolina right
but the proposal was turned down
and the partners to that request were
the Wuhan Institute of virology Ben
whose name is on it but so is Xi Jung
Lee's
so it's pretty obvious that when that
was turned on in 2018
for work for that experiment to be done
in North Carolina
it's not pretty obvious but it's
definitely possible
that the Wuhan Institute of biology said
well we'll go ahead and do the same
experiment in our lab with all our
funding from the Chinese Academy of
Sciences we don't need that Grant to do
that work indeed they may have already
started to do it because uh the the
proposal has some very specific things
in it that that read like the kind of
thing you say when you apply for a grant
for work you've already started and so
one plausible reason why fauci Collins
at all might not want people looking too
closely at this or dwelling on this as
well
let's not look too closely at the fact
that we were that you know our agencies
were funneling money to this sort of
research that maybe we did not directly
fund the creation of this virus in a lab
but kind of like bootstrapping the
technology and then like exporting it
over to China where it's like completely
unsupervised
overarching like perception that they
don't want out there
and Ralph Barrick has played a very
interesting and quite County role in the
debate because uh he did not put his
name he didn't join that conference call
he didn't put his name to the proximal
origin paper he didn't put his name to
the letter and the Lancet he was asked
if he would and said no it's better if I
don't
um uh and he has given one or two
interviews not very many but he gave one
in in 2021 that indicated that he still
that he he thought it was possible that
this thing might have come from a lab so
I think he's I think he's well aware
that the research that he developed but
that was then
um taken on in Wuhan could have led to
the creation of this virus and uh I mean
I'm sure he will deny that that's what
what he thinks happened but I think he's
aware that it could be what's happened
um and and he is really a very critical
uh person now interestingly there's a
there's an exchange between Anthony
fauci and a congressional Committee in
which he uh says something like I don't
know if I've ever met Ralph Barrick
um well we now know that they actually
met very early in the pandemic to
discuss coronavirus biology so boy this
is starting to sound like uh you know
conversations about communist
infiltration in the 1950s or something I
mean there's a lot of skullduggery going
on can I ask in in your opinion is
Anthony fauci and I I don't know how to
put this so uh you know uh uh
felicitously so I'll just do a kind of
bluntly is he deluded or is he corrupt
is he covering his ass or does he really
believe you know that he understands
what happened and he needs to push the
conversation in that direction
I would say to that never underestimate
the human capacity for self-deception
um uh Anthony verchy is the highest paid
federal employee or was until he left
the job uh he's been in that role for
something like 30 years that's
extraordinary isn't it I mean there's
Like the Jagger Hoover of infectious
disease
that's a very good line
um and uh and and his role was immensely
strengthened and made more Imperial if
you like in the wake of the anthrax
events of 2001 when he was effectively
made part of the um
uh when he was made in a sort of Tsar of
the bioterror defense
um research establishment so he's he's
he's you know he's nominally under
Francis Collins at the National
Institute of Health but that's not the
way it works
um he's a he's been an enormously
powerful individual controlling an
enormous amount of funding he's very
articulate he's a fabulous scientist did
wonderful work on on HIV many years ago
when I first knew of his his work
um but I think he has
um
uh dug himself into a hole here that
he's
struggling to dig dig himself out of and
I wouldn't want to use either of the
words you used because I don't know
enough to back them up hey thanks for
watching that clip from our conversation
with Matt Ridley about the origins of
the covid-19 pandemic you can watch
another clip from that conversation
right here or the full conversation
right here